[Music]
in can't remember news submitted by
relationship police Frankie Muniz has
opened up about his health issues and
his struggle with memory loss Boy Meets
World
malcolm in the middle' family matter Oh
Prince he's the main character all bad
guys fallen out of his mind as a young
and dude like he was known for his car
collection at the age of like 16 yeah
yeah and I was picturing the same person
but the different sitcoms kept coming
out of my mouth were you picturing the
right one at least it was him oh you
just didn't know what he was yeah that's
why he was because um but this article
is about amassing the background the
aluminum foil material some [ __ ] that
doesn't matter okay well he's posing for
Dancing with the Stars
oh he explains aluminum foil now looks
like wall insulation it looks like a
great photo yes it is a good way if he
has memory loss how can he remember all
the dance moves of a Frankie you didn't
dance at all so during the density of
the stars they had like a pre-taped
package it was the most memorable year
night that was like the theme of this
night and so when he was being
interviewed he's 31 by the way Theatre
Wow yeah I wouldn't he would have been
40 by now he was younger than us right
when we were watching the show or like
the Saint yeah that's what few years
younger
yes no maybe I don't know
you had memory law
can you repeat please question yes
during this pre-taped package that's
when he opened up about the fact that he
has many health issues and one of those
is the fact that he just doesn't have
any long-term memory he doesn't really
remember even filming that show why yeah
so he was saying that he's not much of a
doctor person because every time you
thought of the doctors they'd make it
seem like he's crazy he's Asian
let's try starting with doctor yeah so
he doesn't really go to doctors he
hasn't really found out why he has these
memory issues because doctors can't
figure it out either Oh was it that's no
boy accident he had so he has had nine
concussion I made up the snowboard
accident I like how doctors don't
believe him
this was a professional boxer yeah
what's going on or they can't find
what's wrong with you yeah we can't and
then because of that he just doesn't go
anymore he he did suffer a serious car
crash back in 2009 while he was
competing as a professional racecar
drivers okay
that's one of them fun ass life I don't
know the rest well he forgot that life
it somehow led to him having these mini
strokes well I don't really give him the
same effect there's like a full blown
stroke but then that's also like causing
issues with the memory stuff too huh but
he's nothing it's directly caused by
that but how can you even trust what he
says yeah he doesn't notice how -
remembering yeah uh we should trust him
to be honest yeah I remember what you
think he was just mentioning like over
the past ten years
his mom was bringing up stories of you
know the of his life and you just can't
remember it all these stories are new
stories to him uh if I was his brother I
would throw them so hard I'll be like
dude remember the time when you suck the
neighbors did Oh remember the time when
you [ __ ] the goat at the petting zoo
dude don't so crazy
that must suck because I feel like when
you get older you start thinking like as
soon as you forget anything you're like
a [ __ ] I'm getting old and then you're
like worried about Alzheimer's and
Alzheimer's all time old timers timers I
can't imagine being like 30 and not
remembering the first like half of your
life that's true especially because his
show was so influential dude he's the
one who built Walter White you know we
have a ya know his dad was bought to
wipe from brain crime he was also part
of the package thing too he was saying
how like he tells him not to worry about
his memory or like not dude you don't
he's like forget about it there's still
your experiences that will be my job I
will tell him remember this remember
that I told you I don't remember it it's
like the notebook yes oh then I
concluding this whole package Malcolm
was saying Malcolm Frankie yes his most
memorable year is 2017 because he's
learning to live in the present and his
girlfriend has been helping him try to
remember their experiences so she's
keeping this journal where she writes
like in detail and he reads it every one
down ass [ __ ] dude that's [ __ ] crazy
dude so cool especially in a you know
world of YouTube where she could just
evolve everything I know I was just
thinking that I was like man because you
know every year at the end of the year I
am i watch all my vlogs through the year
and it's like a little like a highlight
reel and when I see bad guys see what I
did this you are such a narcissist
I'm just kidding I do the same thing
where youtubers sometimes watch like all
of our vacations together and I'm like
that was a great moment wasn't it guys
yeah cuz I totally buried the negative
part like maybe I was behind fighting
with Jess or something was happening but
all I remember is the fakeness in the
blog is that and that's like the awesome
[ __ ] yeah yes I mean you know all about
Frankie though he looks just like he did
when he was a kid yeah adult like but
like child actors that growth be [ __ ]
hideous not the subset scheme [ __ ]
hideous but he looks different
he was hey hailey Joe Osmond yeah he was
really cute kid and as a doll he was in
all those kid movie things and he will
exist that that boy innocent face Oh
Matilda her - oh she knocks a little not
a little different she looks exactly
like how she looks and she was a kid but
like in grown-up form and she got
titties awesome drew Barrymore it was a
nice nice ah yes yes yes yes transition
very nice yeah she's super cute is he a
man yeah and hot as it older yeah yeah
Britney Spears baby Nikki mouse Mickey
Mouse Club I don't know I'm just asking
all right I'm not talking about now I
still smash Britney now I haven't seen
her in a minister like she smells like I
saw her on Instagram painting in an a
mansion painting a painting that she
look I feel like that's like the route
that every artist goes through when they
have a mental breakdown they become a
painter Jim Carrey
oh yeah he's doing that right now I saw
that I can't wait till one of them just
exposes the Illuminati please come out
already
I just lurk online and I'm just waiting
for all these there's so many fake video
what if they shoot Carrie is exposing
the Illuminati i watch for 50 minutes
nothing [ __ ] happens gonna get mean
you know what's cool about this though I
think I'm being a little too negative
because the awesome part is you can
watch all the shows from the beginning
and you could be like dad this is a good
show cuz you'll remember it I saw my own
skits so like I can't look at it like an
audience I always look at my own things
as a creator but then if I looked at it
from fresh eyes I can tell myself if I
suck or not I feel that I feel that like
if you don't remember doing it and
you're like and you can watch it as like
like a like a unbiased judge yeah weird
word you know it's you but you don't
remember making it so you don't know
what's gonna happen next
and you get surprised yeah I thought
some comment that they were saying about
Frankie here they were just saying like
oh that's cool you could just watch the
whole sitcom without spoilers true
question question would you want to be
Frankie Muniz do you like yourself now
and would you trade place with Frankie
Muniz so you have all this money but you
forget all the [ __ ] all the time one of
the question again like would you would
you want to trade you that
got that [ __ ] I got money and
rich then me breakeven is this [ __ ]
he's super rich and he has sent the kid
of money to hear that rich so you think
he's not richer than you in my heart I'm
really rich cuz I got a lot of friends
so by the by the time he was already
like 14 there's also a multi-millionaire
I love my memories though
yeah man you can't you can't trade in
your memories I think as your memories
is important as a comedian too it's like
you have to be able to recall and then
[ __ ] you know and you are who you are
because your memories like all the
things you went through that's right if
you like to dick for no reason and then
now people know why the [ __ ] of your
[ __ ] and you can't even remember all
the times I got picked on now you're
just a dude for no reason but if you get
these back it up you know I had this
happen to me just happen to be booked in
Malaysia I don't care
he has a better life imma take it the
beauty of getting your money is
remembering how broke you were damn dude
I just want to [ __ ] duffle bag full
of money though that's what my mom says
till she goes I told my mom I was like
hey I really wish I could win the
lottery she goes but that's not money
your money cuz you didn't earn it I was
like really what if I gave you half of
it she goes that's perfectly fine
exactly
give me a Duff if it's gonna make you
feel better give it to me I don't know I
think his life is amazing cuz he's on
Dancing with the Stars and they don't I
can't even go on the show cuz I'm not a
star
yeah Bryan Cranston was saying that like
he's lived such an amazing like he's
done things that other people dream of
course so many careers that other people
dream of like the racecar driving that
being in a band and just pursuing music
he was in a series that's literally a
cult classic now yeah I mean like
everybody will know what Malcolm in the
middle is and people will refer back to
that show what if his life just keeps
resetting that's why he doesn't remember
[ __ ] like he was a TV star then he
forgot it all he's like I'm with you I
want to be a race car driver
want to race cars and in race cars a
long time got into the accident forgot
all that [ __ ] and I was like I'm a
professional dancer on TV you know
what's but I feel [ __ ] up because like
you said he had nine concussions I just
pictured him walking outside of coconuts
keep hitting his head
an ACME character saltine damn how many
actual strokes is that add up to what
was that ma'am that memory movie where
they come in and they take away all your
bad like memories sunshine of the
spotless mind yeah I'd do that any day
everyone is flowing we haven't seen it
yet you're not gonna watch you like you
should watch it isn't really the film
huh it's a good film hey guys thanks for
watching that last episode did you love
it yes you did so don't forget to
subscribe if this your first time you're
here we've upload every single day so
don't miss an upload now to watch more
episodes check them out okay
[Music]